What's up everybody!
We are Pongfinity
And today we won't be needing these
Because we are playing with other sports equipment.
Let's find out which one is best for table
tennis!
I've been preparing for the big fight
Against the extremely lightweight champion.
Skiing is not my strong point
But I'm sure that I can play table tennis
with this ski.
We are going to play a match to 5 points
I'm going to be using the badminton racket
And I'm going to be using the tennis racket.
But first, we are going to need some practice.
Okay I think next we'll have to play with
a frisbee.
But since we only have one frisbee
That means me and Miikka will have to share
it.
This should be fun!
Here is a challenge to all you football players
out there
I'm gonna see if it's possible to play
While bouncing the ball.
Now that we are warmed up, it's time for the
big match.
He is going to have no chance.
We'll see that!
We had a lot of fun filming this episode
Let us know in the comments below
Which one was your favorite item!
If you enjoyed this episode make sure to leave
it a thumbs up!
Subscribe right here
And watch our previous episodes here.
Until next time!